whoever said 'i bikes aren't for sporty
people was wrong the range of models is
bigger than ever a touch of a button is
all it takes to get you across town but
could it replace a car mattias blue
mussels the 32 year old has started
manufacturing his own bikes just outside
of munich is [ __ ] and farmers on fire
I always wanted to make bicycles I've
been racing since I was a child yeah
what and then in 2009 my girlfriend got
me into e-bikes I've got another phone
and what else he back is excellent I
immediately love the idea I just didn't
like any of the bikes I saw so I thought
hey why don't I just make my own ok pero
hasta could follow us understand one
with Agnes month it took my tears and
his team 18 months to develop the model
they spent a lot of time fiddling with
the motor setup and this year they
received the bavarian state award for
outstanding technical achievement
it's belong on gimme Vegas what's so
special about this ebike is its built-in
propulsion system which we developed
ourselves each part is incorporated into
the bicycle fork the battery is located
right down here file and the electronic
control system here deadlight the motor
is on the side that's why the bikes
really light because the motorways only
four to five kilos yep this funk it'll
be that brings the overall weight right
down a feather-light 16 kilograms as
opposed to the average 25 to 34 an
e-bike more models and manufacturers are
appearing on the market every year the
battery-operated motor allows for a
smooth ride even when going uphill you
switch it on by pedaling or by hitting a
button can elementary bikes is now the
battery is the most essential component
of the ebike you can't write a thought
when I don't do it it takes two to four
hours to load it up that'll leave you
with enough power to travel at least 40
kilometers depending on the electricity
provider it costs ten to twenty cents
per charge this model has little in
common with the clunky first generation
e-bikes Iranian German architect hadita
hey Donny designed the first one it took
him a year to develop that a hopeful
casa improve as far as the primary focus
was on making up the fewer bike we
didn't want to create some kind of
motorcycle bike mutable I absolutely
insisted it remain a bicycle a very
elegant slicker minimalist bike where
the motor is integrated into the front
wheel like my in in there and in father
at the interiors this ebike costs over
2,000 euros to Hourani wanted the
battery indicator to be inconspicuous
and the battery removable I'm going to
lose
we found a solution by saying this is
like a briefcase that I'm cycling around
with spend I take the briefcase home
with me in the evening and I can charge
my batteries up there vladan most ebikes
can cruise up to speeds of 25 kilometers
an hour anything that goes faster
requires a license there's bath on
Electra for me what's fun about the
electric bike is the acceleration
offered by the additional motor that
explains the fascination with electric
bikes to pass tinatanong electrified our
environmentally friendly and fast the
street sweeper is aptly named
you